des pays comme l'Inde, la Russie, Afrique du Sud, le Brésil et même la Chine
sont maintenant en-dessous de 7%
et, dans de nombreux cas, régressent.
La croissance économique est importante.
Avec la croissance économique,
les pays et les sociétés entrent dans un cercle vertueux
de mobilité sociale, d'opportunités et d'amélioration du niveau de vie.
Sans croissance, les pays se contractent et s'atrophient,
pas seulement dans les annales des statistiques économiques
mais aussi dans le sens de la vie et comment nous la vivons.
La croissance économique est importante pour les individus.
Si la croissance baisse,
le risque pour le progrès humain
et le risque de l'instabilité politique et sociale, augmente.
Les sociétés s'assombrissent.
Le contexte est important.
Et les pays en développement
n'ont pas besoin de croître au même taux que les pays développés.
Maintenant, je sais que certains d'entre vous y voient une proposition risquée.
Il y a des gens ici
qui vont se retourner et être tout à fait désenchantés
par ce qui arrive dans le monde
et attribuent ça à la croissance économique.
Vous vous inquiétez de la surpopulation de la planète.
En voyant les récentes statistiques et projections de l'ONU
qui disent que le monde atteindra 11 milliards d'habitants
avant qu'il ne plafonne en 2100,
les conséquences sur les ressources naturelles vous préoccupent -
les terres arables, l'eau potable, l'énergie et les minéraux.
Vous êtes également préoccupés par la dégradation de l'environnement.
Et vous vous inquiétez de la façon dont l'homme,
pro-mondialiste,
est devenu avide et corrompu.
Mais je suis ici pour vous dire aujourd'hui que la croissance économique
a été la colonne vertébrale de changements dans le niveau de vie
de millions de gens à travers le monde.
Et plus important encore,
le capitalisme n'a pas seulement entraîné la croissance économique.
La définition du capitalisme, très simplement,
est que les facteurs de production
tels que le commerce et l'industrie, le capital et le travail,
sont laissés entre les mains du secteur privé et non de l’État.
C'est vraiment essentiel que nous comprenions que,
fondamentalement, la critique ne concerne pas la croissance économique en soi
mais ce qui est arrivé au capitalisme.
Et dans la mesure où nous avons besoin de croissance économique soutenable,
nous allons devoir la soutenir intelligemment.
La croissance économique a besoin du capitalisme,
mais d'une manière légitime.
Et comme je le disais il y a un instant,
le cœur du système capitaliste a été défini par des acteurs privés.
C'est une dichotomie très simpliste.
Capitalisme : bien. Non-capitalisme : mauvais.
En expérience pratique,
le capitalisme est beaucoup plus un spectre.
Nous avons des pays comme la Chine,
qui ont pratiqué plus de capitalisme d’État,
et nous avons des pays comme les États-Unis,
plutôt capitalistes de marché.
Nos efforts pour critiquer le système capitaliste, cependant,
ont tendance à se concentrer sur des pays comme la Chine,
qui ne sont en fait pas ouverts au capitalisme de marché.
Cependant, il existe une vraie raison et véritable préoccupation,
de nous concentrer sur les formes les plus pures du capitalisme,
en particulier celles incarnées par les États-Unis.
C'est très important,
ce type de capitalisme
a, de plus en plus, été critiqué :
il favoriserait la corruption,
et pire encore,
il augmenterait les inégalités de revenus -
l'idée que quelques uns profitent au détriment de la majorité.
Les deux questions critiques auxquelles nous devons répondre
sont de savoir comment réparer le capitalisme
pour qu'il crée de la croissance économique
et en même temps résolve les problèmes sociaux.
Pour ça, nous devons nous demander : comment le capitalisme
fonctionne-t-il aujourd'hui ?
Très simplement :
le capitalisme maximise l'utilité individuelle
d'une personne égoïste qui fait ce qu'elle veut.
Et seulement après avoir maximisé leur utilité,
ils décident que c'est important
de fournir un soutien à d'autres.
Bien entendu, dans ce système, les gouvernements lèvent l'impôt,
et l'utilisent pour financer les programmes sociaux,
reconnaissant qu'ils ne servent pas juste à réglementer
mais aussi à arbitrer les biens sociaux.
Néanmoins,
ce cadre -
ce cadre en deux étapes -
est ce à partir de quoi il faut commencer
à réfléchir afin d'améliorer le modèle capitaliste.
Je dirais que ce défi a deux facettes.
Tout d'abord,
nous pouvons utiliser les politiques de droite
et voir ce qui pourrait être bénéfique
pour améliorer le capitalisme.
En particulier,
les politiques de droite
ont tendance à se concentrer sur les échanges réciproques ;
nous payons et récompensons des personnes qui ont agi
de manière à aider la croissance.
Par exemple,
envoyer les enfants à l'école
pourrait justifier une rémunération des parents
ou encore après avoir fait vacciner ou immuniser ses enfants,
les parents pourraient être payés.
Maintenant, au-delà du débat
quant à savoir si nous devrions payer les gens
pour faire ce qu'ils font, de toute façon,
le fait est que la rémunération au rendement
a effectivement donné des résultats positifs
dans des pays comme le Mexique,
le Brésil,
et également lors d’expériences à New York.
Il y a aussi des bénéfices
et des changements significatifs concernants les politiques de gauche.
Les arguments qui disent que le gouvernement devrait élargir son rôle
afin qu'il ne soit pas si étroitement défini,
et qu'il devrait être beaucoup plus qu'un arbitre
des facteurs de production,
sont devenus monnaie courante grâce à la Chine.
Nous avons aussi commencé à avoir des débats
sur la question du secteur privé,
s'il devrait ne plus avoir qu'un but lucratif,
mais être plus engagé dans les programmes sociaux.
Les programmes engageant la responsabilité sociale des entreprises
même à petite échelle,
vont dans la bonne direction.
Bien sûr, les politiques de gauche ont aussi eu tendance à brouiller les lignes
entre le gouvernement, les ONG et le secteur privé.
Un premier exemple se passe aux 19ème siècle aux États-Unis,
lorsque le déploiement des infrastructures concernait les partenariats public-privé.
Le deuxième exemple est
l'avènement d'Internet, qui a prouvé au monde entier
que le public et le privé pouvaient s'allier pour améliorer la société.
Mon message est donc le suivant :
nous ne pouvons pas résoudre les défis de la croissance économique
en étant dogmatiques et inutilement idéologiques.
Afin de créer une croissance durable, et de résoudre
les défis sociaux, qui continuent aujourd'hui d'affliger le monde,
nous allons devoir ouvrir notre esprit
pour trouver une solution.
En fin de compte,
nous devons reconnaître que l'idéologie est l'ennemi de la croissance.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani :Puis-je poser quelques questions, Dambisa ?
On pourrait dire que la croissance est aussi une idéologie,
que c'est peut-être l'idéologie dominante de notre époque.
Qu'avez-vous à dire à ceux qui réagissent comme ça ?
DM: Je pense que cela est tout à fait légitime,
je pense que nous avons déjà cette discussion.
Il y a beaucoup de travail autour du bonheur
et d'autres métriques utilisées pour mesurer le succès des populations
et l'amélioration du niveau de vie.
Je pense donc que nous devrions être ouverts
à ce qui pourrait apporter des améliorations de niveau de vie
et continuer de réduire la pauvreté.
BG : Vous plaidez pour la réhabilitation de la croissance
mais pour que cela se produise
sans compromettre la capacité de la Terre
à se régénérer,
est que la croissance économique
se découple de l'utilisation des ressources.
Est-ce ce qu'il se passe ?
DM : Eh bien, je suis optimiste envers l'ingéniosité humaine.
Je pense que si nous commençons à nous
contraindre quant à l'utilisation de nos ressources rares,
comme nous le savons,
nous serions assez pessimistes et préoccupés par le monde d'aujourd'hui.
Cependant, nous avons vu avec le Club de Rome,
nous l'avons entendu avec des propos plus anciens :
le monde serait à court de ressources,
et je ne dis pas que ce n'est pas vrai. Mais je pense
qu'avec ingéniosité nous pourrions dessaler,
nous pourrions réinvestir dans l'énergie
afin d'obtenir des résultats durables.
Et donc, dans ce sens,
je suis optimiste de ce qu'on pourrait faire.
BG : La chose qui me frappe
dans vos propositions pour réhabiliter la croissance
et prendre une direction différente,
est que vous suggérez de réparer le capitalisme avec plus de capitalisme -
récompenser les bons comportements,
donner un plus grand rôle aux entreprises à propos des questions sociales.
Est-ce ce que vous proposez ?
DM : Je suggère d'ouvrir notre esprit.
Je pense que c'est absolument le cas,
les modèles traditionnels de croissance économique
ne prennent pas le chemin que nous voulons.
Ce n'est pas un hasard
si aujourd'hui la plus grande économie du monde, les États-Unis,
est une démocratie,
une démocratie libérale,
avec une économie de marché -
dans la mesure où elle est libre -
comme fondement économique.
La seconde plus grande économie est la Chine.
Ils ont dépriorisé la démocratie
et ont un capitalisme d’État. C'est un modèle totalement différent.
Ces deux pays ont des modèles politiques très différents,
de même pour leurs modèles économiques,
et pourtant ils ont les mêmes inégalités de revenus
selon le coefficient de Gini.
Je pense que ces débats, nous devrions les avoir,
car nous ne savons pas clairement quel modèle adopter.
Je pense qu'il doit y avoir beaucoup plus débats,
d'humilité à propos de ce que nous savons et ce que nous ne savons pas.
BG : Une dernière question à propos de la COP21 qui se passe à Paris.
Si vous pouviez envoyer un tweet
à tous les chefs d’État et chefs de délégation présents,
que diriez-vous ?
DM : Encore une fois, plus d'ouverture d'esprit.
Comme vous le savez,
les préoccupations environnementales
ont été discutées de nombreuses fois -
à Copenhague, en 1972 à Stockholm -
et nous continuons de reprendre ces questions,
en partie, parce qu'il n'y a pas d'accord fondamental,
en fait, il y a un schisme
entre ce que les pays développés pensent et veulent
et ce que les pays émergents veulent.
Les pays émergents ont besoin de continuer à créer de la croissance économique
afin d'éviter des problèmes politiques majeurs.
Les pays développés reconnaissent
qu'ils ont une vraie responsabilité,
non seulement quant à la gestion de leurs émissions de CO2
et d'une partie de la dégradation à laquelle ils contribuent,
mais aussi pour innover en R&D.
Alors, ils doivent s’asseoir à la table aussi.
Mais il ne peut pas y avoir une situation
où nous attribuons certaines politiques aux pays émergents,
sans contraindre les pays développés,
à s'en prendre à
la demande et l'offre de leurs marchés développés.
BG : Dambisa, merci d'être venue à TED. DM : Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)